il y avait moins de partisans que
l'année dernière à la grande messe
conservatrice de CIPAC en banlieue de
Washington ce week-end ce n'est plus le
parti républicain qui se réunit mais de
plus en plus le parti de Donald Trump
plusieurs absents dont l'ancien
vice-prés
le gouverneur de la Floride et étoile
montante du parti
il faut qu'on ait une solution de
rechange à download dit-il on n'a pas
besoin d'être dirigé par l'arrogance et
la vengeance
il faut éliminer Trump du processus de
nomination le plus vite possible dit-il
et ne pas répéter l'erreur de 2016
celui qu'on surnommé le mini Trump
est-il en train de dépasser son maître
l'homme de Saint-Tite choisit dimanche
de livrer son discours non pas aussi
Pâques mais la bibliothèque Reagan en
Californie devant un parterre de
conservateur
[Applaudissements]
de l'éducation dit-il et contre
l'endoctrinement dans nos écoles
il martèle le même message contre ce
qu'il appelle l'idéologie walk contre
l'éducation sexuelle et raciale à
l'école et sur les questions de genre
plein de sentis n'a pas encore
officiellement présenté sa candidature
alors que Nicky Heli l'ancienne
ambassadrice aux Nations Unies il a fait
si vous êtes fatigué de perdre dit-elle
ayez confiance dans la nouvelle
génération
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis le seul candidat addit-il qui
peut prévenir une troisième guerre
mondiale et il y en aura une si quelque
chose ne se passe pas rapidement et je
règlerai le conflit en une seule journée
ajoutée rien de moins pour l'ancien
président qui s'en prend aussi à son
parti
nous avions un parti tenu par des fous
dit-il des néoc conservateurs
globalisent qui veulent ouvrir nos
frontières nous ne reviendrons pas en
arrière
il y va de promesses en promesse malgré
les multiples enquêtes judiciaires
auxquelles il fait face il affirme que
même s'il est inculpé ça ne l'empêchera
pas d'être candidat à la présidence pour
une troisième fois
et les électeurs lui semblent fidèles
le duel dort dans notre chambre rounds
semble inévitable d'ici lundi prochain
les deux candidats seront en AOA au
seindra le premier vote de l'investiture
républicaine ce qui donnera un
avant-goût de la campagne qui risque
d'être sans merci ici